THOUGHT THIS DAY WAS GOING TO
COME AS I LOOK AT PHIL BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN A LONG THREE YEARS.
THE U.S. COVID PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IS SET TO END
THURSDAY.
THE U.S. WILL NO LONGER PROVIDE
MANY AMERICANS WITH FREE COVID
TESTS, TREATMENT, VACCINES AT NO
COST.
>> THIS COMES AS THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION MADE A
SIMILAR DECLARATION LAST WEEK
MORE THAN THREE YEARS AFTER THE
GLOBAL PANDEMIC THAT CLAIMED
NEARLY 7 MILLION LIVES AROUND
THE WORLD.
OUR CHIEF MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT
DR. SANJAY GUPTA GUIDED US,
THANK GOODNESS FOR HIM, THROUGH
THE UPS, THE DOWNS, THE MASKS,
THE TESTS, THE VACCINES FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING WHEN CNN FIRST
STARTED CALLING THIS A PANDEMIC.
>> THERE ARE CRITERIA THAT ARE
SOMEWHAT DEFYING TO CALL
SOMETHING A PANDEMIC.
LET ME SAY THAT THIS TERMINOLOGY
THAT WE ARE GOING TO START USING
NOW ISN'T SO MUCH TO CAUSE PANIC
BUT RATHER TO REALLY CAUSE A
FOCUS ON PREPAREDNESS.
>> GUPTA HAS GUIDED US THROUGH
IT ALL.
GOOD MORNING.
I'M CALLING YOU DR. GUPTA THIS
MORNING.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE BEEN FOR
US.
YOU MADE US FEEL -- YOU HELPED
US UNDERSTAND SOMETHING SO SCARY
FOR SO MANY PEOPLE.
THIS MORNING YOUR ESSAY IS SO
GREAT BECAUSE YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT OUR COUNTRY AS YOUR
PATIENT AGAIN.
SO WHERE ARE WE?
>> I THINK FOR SOME PEOPLE THIS
IS GOING TO SEEM VERY ARBITRARY
AND ACCELERATED THAT THE
EMERGENCY PART OF THIS PANDEMIC
IS COMING TO AN END.
FOR OTHER PEOPLE, THEY WILL SAY,
HEY LOOK, MONTHS AGO, MAYBE A
YEAR AGO I WAS SORT OF THROUGH
THIS.
SO IT'S PRETTY DIVIDED IN TERMS
OF HOW PEOPLE THINK ABOUT THIS.
AS YOU MENTIONED, THE W.H.O.
ALREADY ENDED THEIR PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY OF
INTERNATIONAL CONCERN.
THE CDC DIRECTOR IN THIS COUNTRY
IS STEPPING DOWN JUNE 30th.
AND THURSDAY THE UNITED STATES
IS GOING TO END THE EMERGENCY AS
WELL.
THE WAY THAT IT'S WORKED IS THAT
THERE HAS BEEN EMERGENCIES THAT
LASTED 90 DAYS AND THEY HAVE
BEEN SORT OF RENEWED 13 TIMES.
SO THAT LAST RENEWAL ENDED MAY
11.
AT THAT POINT IT'S EXPECTED NOT
TO BE RENEWED AGAIN.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
I WILL TELL YOU, AS YOU
MENTIONED, POPPY, YOU KNOW, I
SORT OF THOUGHT METAPHORICALLY
OF THE COUNTRY AS MY PATIENT.
I FELT LIKE IT WAS THE BEST WAY
TO THINK ABOUT THIS.
I REALLY MEANT IT.
IF YOU LOOK AT HOW THE PATIENT
IS DOING NOW AND SORT OF LOOK AT
THE PATIENT CHART, IF YOU WILL,
THE LAST THREE YEARS AND A FEW
MONTHS, I CAN SHOW YOU SORT OF
WHERE CASES ARE NOW.
IN THE BEGINNING, WHEN THE
PANDEMIC WAS DECLARED, IT WAS --
THERE WERE JUST A FEW CASES.
NOW YOU CAN SEE THE CASES HAVE
TRICKLED DOWN.
YOU SAW SOME BIG SURGES IN THE
MIDDLE THERE.
THAT'S WHEN THE PATIENT WAS
UNSTABLE, ENDED UP IN THE ICU,
NEEDED ALL SORTS OF CARE.
77,000 CASES STILL A WEEK, TO
GIVE YOU SOME IDEA.
HOSPITALIZATIONS, AGAIN, YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE LAST THREE YEARS
AND FEW MONTHS OF THIS PANDEMIC
AND WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
THE NUMBERS ARE TRENDING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION, ABOUT 1,200
PEOPLE IN THE HOSPITAL RIGHT
NOW, AND THEN, FINALLY, DEATHS.
AGAIN, WHEN WE DECLARED THIS A
PANDEMIC THERE HADN'T BEEN ANY
DEATHS IN THE UNITED STATES YET.
BUT THE TREND LINE WAS VERY
CONCERNING.
YOU COULD SEE THAT ALMOST
STRAIGHT UP LINE IN THE
BEGINNING AND THEN THE VARIOUS
SURGES AND NOW THERE IS ABOUT
1,100 PEOPLE WHO ARE DYING EVERY
WEEK STILL FROM COVID.
SO YOU GET AN IDEA THERE.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU DO THE MATH
ON THIS, 1,100 PEOPLE A WEEK,
THAT'S ABOUT 54, 55,000 A YEAR
THAT WOULD DIE IF THOSE NUMBERS
STAY THE SAME, WHICH IS
BASICALLY A REALLY BAD FLU
SEASON.
WE COULD DO BETTER, BUT THAT'S
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW AND
THAT'
THAT
SEEMS WHAT THE COUNTRY IS
WILLING TO TOLERATE.
>> SANJAY, I AM GOING TO CALL
YOU BECAUSE YOU BECAME A PART OF
OUR FAMILY AND EVERYBODY ELSE'S
FAMILY, WE RELIED ON YOU THE
LAST THREE YEARS.
WHAT KIND OF CHANGES SHOULD WE
EXCEPT ON A PERSONAL LEVEL WITH
THE END OF THE EMERGENCY?
THERE ARE TANGIBLE REPERCUSSIONS
HERE?
>> YEAH, THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE WATCHING RIGHT
NOW AND ARE WORRIED.
I HAVE PEOPLE IN MY OWN FAMILY
BECAUSE OF THEIR PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS, THEIR AGE, THEY ARE
WORRIED.
THE TANGIBLE THINGS, PHIL, FREE
TESTING AND FREE THERAPEUTICS,
TREATMENTS, WILL NO LONGER BE
FREE.
YOU MAY BE ABLE TO GET THOSE
THROUGH YOUR INSURANCE
COMPANIES.
THE MAPS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
SHOWING WHERE COMMUNITY SPREAD,
WHERE THE VIRUS IS SPREADING IN
COMMUNITIES AT ANY GIVEN TIME,
THOSE WEATHER MAPS, WON'T BE
EASY TO ACCESS ANYMORE BECAUSE
THAT DATA WON'T BE SHARED.
VACCINES WILL STILL BE AVAILABLE
AND THEY WILL STILL BE FREE.
YET YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO GET THOSE.
GOING BACK TO SAYING SO MUCH OF
THE COUNTRY MOVED ON, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE UP-TO-DATE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE OF
VACCINES, YOU ARE UNDER 20% OF
THE COUNTRY IS UP TO DATE ON
THEIR VACCINES.
BY THE WAY, WITH FLU, IT'S
AROUND HALF THE COUNTRY EVERY
YEAR THAT ACTUALLY WILL GET A
FLU SHOT.
SO THEY ARE NOT VERY -- THERE IS
NOT A LOT OF WILL TO GET THE
VACCINES BUT THEY WILL STILL BE
AVAILABLE.
>> OF COURSE, THE QUESTION IS
SHOULD PEOPLE STILL WEAR MASKS?
WHAT THINGS CAN THEY DO TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES?
I THINK SHOULD IS NOT THE RIGHT
WORD.
I STILL SEE PEOPLE WEARING MASKS
AND I RESPECT THAT AND IT'S
THEIR DECISION.
WHAT ARE THINGS THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD CHANGE ON THURSDAY, OR
NOT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WITH REGARD TO
MASKS, THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
STILL VULNERABLE.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO WEAR A MASK,
WEAR A WELL FITTING HIGH QUALITY
MASK.
THOSE WORK.
A COUPLE THINGS QUICK LILT.
I THINK THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
LESSONS HERE.
THE UNITED STATES GOT HIT
PARTICULARLY HARD BY THIS
PANDEMIC.
THERE IS ALL SORTS OF REASONS
FOR THAT.
ONE OF THE BIG ONES IS WE WERE
NOT VERY HEALTHY GOING INTO THIS
PANDEMIC.
WE KNEW THAT AGE WAS A BIG RISK
FACTOR, BUT ALSO PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS.
AND YOU CAN LOOK LOOT AT SOME OF
THESE PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS,
YOU KNOW, THINGS, OBESITY PUTS
YOU AT MUCH HIGHER RISK,
UNDERLYING KIDNEY DISEASE,
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE, THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS INCREASED THE
RISK SIGNIFICANTLY.
WEALTH DOES NOT BUY HEALTH.
GOT TO KEEP THAT IN MIND.
WE NEED TO GET HEALTHY AS A
NATION
NATION.
A QUICK INSPIRATIONAL NOTE IS
THAT IF YOU HAVE IMMUNITY
AGAINST THIS VIRUS, IF YOU HAVE
ACCESS TO ANTIVIRALS LIKE
PAXLOVID, THERE IS NO REASON
ANYONE SHOULD DIE OF THIS
DISEASE ANY MORE.
WE HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING.
>> TO BE ABLE TO SAY THAT, IT
TOOK THREE CAREERS, BUT TO BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.